*Musique entraînante de jeu vidéo*
Eh bien bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette... (rires)
Elle est très sympa la musique de ce jeu non ? On aurait dit un peu Mario.
- Micka : Ah, moi je pensais à Friends
- Squeezie : Ou Mario dans Friends, on sait pas.
-Squeezie : Alors, aujourd'hui on est sur Jogger Nauts. C'est un jeu qui se joue en coopération.
C'est un petit jeu que j'ai trouvé, j'ai demandé aux développeurs de me l'envoyer, et ils ont gentiment accepté.
- Micka : Oooh !
-Squeezie : C'était il y a six mois que je leur ai demandé. Ça fait 6 mois qu'ils attendent ! (rires)
En gros, on va jouer un perso bleu et un perso rouge. Ils avancent tout seuls. Face à eux des fois vont se trouver des portails bleus ou rouges.
Il faut que le perso de nous deux qui est devant, soit celui de la même couleur que le portail qui arrive.
Moi je vais prendre le poisson, comme ça je suis bien reconnaissable, et toi ?
-Micka : Je prends la chose, moi. (rire)
-Squeezie : Ok vasi tu prends la chose, c'est parti.
Donc le seul qui peut appuyer, c'est celui qui est derrière. Hop, pour passer devant.
Ok je passe devant ! Passe devant, oh put***...
Put*** mer** j'ai oublié ! Et toi mais put*** !
-Micka : Mais tu m'as stressé !
-Squeezie : Ok on refait, on refait, on refait. Oh, c''est génial ! (rire)
(rire)
Normalement, faut dire Switch, faut dire Switch, quand tu veux dire à l'autre de Switcher.
-Micka : Sinon t'as plus le droit de Switcher
Switch !
-Squeezie et Mika : Switch !
-Squeezie : Nintendo ! *clin d'œil*
-Micka : Switch ! -Squeezie : OHHH ! -Micka : Switch !
-Squeezie et Mika : Noooon !
-Micka : Switch !
-Squeezie : Switch !
Oh put*** t'étais limite frère ! (rire)
-Squeezie : Oh on a pas eu ! -Mika : Swi' swi' switch ! -Squeezie : Oh put*** non ! -Mika : Tout de suite, tout de suite ! Oh non ! (rire)
-Micka : Ca ressemble à rien ! (rire) -Squeezie : Mec ça casse le cerveau c'est infernal !
-Squeezie : Allez on s'appelle, hein. (rire de Mickalow) Oh non !
-Squeezie : Allez les joueurs français,les joueurs français...
-Micka : Et là tu Switch   -Squeezie:..les joueurs français.Tu Switch.
-Squeezie:WOOOOOW !
-Squeezie: NOON !
-Micka: Non,pardon.
-Squeezie: NOOON !!
-Micka: Non ,non j'ai stressé !  -Squeezie :Non, c'est moi, c'est moi, c'est moi j'ai confondu !
-Micka:À toi,à toi !
-Squeezie:Attends,non ! J'étais entrain,j'étais entrain
-Squeezie:MAIS NOON !
-Squeezie:Mais désolé de vouloir animer la vidéo.Mais non !
-Squeezie:Attends,pause.
-Squeezie:Allumons une allumette.
*Musique*
*Micka souffle puis rit*
-Squeezie:T'as fais quoi ?
Squeezie : Micka s'te plaît...
Micka : On est au niveau 1 (1)
Squeezie :  On est au niveau 1 mec c'est chaud quand même
Squeezie : Allez on y va c'est parti donc là c'est moi qui appuie
Squeezie : MAIS TU FAIS QUOI MICKAAA - Micka : j'ai stressé, j'ai stressé, j'ai stressé
Squeezie : On a plus le droit à l'erreur Micka !
Micka : Justement ça donne du stress regarde
Squezzie : Bon tu vas en bas, je vais en haut! Tu vas en bas je vais en haut!
Squeezie : Switch!
Micka: Nan!
Squeeze: Nan fallait re-switch!
Squeezie: C'est dur!
Squeezie: Le niveau 1 est si dur
Squeezie: Oh beau goss!
micka: j'sais pas c'que sait squezzie: c'est vraiment stylé c'que tu viens de faire
Squezzie: SWITCH
Micka: p**** tu m'as stressé squezzie: AAAH SWITCH
squezzie et micka: OOOOH oh naaaan
*rire*
Squeezie: Oh attend attend, je suis désolé , (pète) oh ça m'a mis mal
Micka: C'est la pression *rire*
Micka: Ah pas de réaction
Squeezie: Mais t'as fait quoi? *rire* mais t'as fait quoi? *rire*
Micka :Non
Squeezie: Putain mec no fake quoi
Rire
Mais mec attend pas la dernière seconde Micka
Micka regarde arrête de faire sa
oh mais on a fait un perfect
attend je vais dans le bâtiment en haut t'es un fils de ******
est mais attend on a fait un perfect
oue oue oue oue
Micka : j'vois pas pourquoi tu tes exciter
Squeezie : nan mais tu vois très bien pourquoi je me suis exciter
switch
Aaaah a ok faut que je saute du coup c'est chaud
switch switch
Squeezie : mais c'est toi qui était derrière c'est toi qui devais switcher
switch
Squeezie : Mais putain tu me fait rater mon saut
Micka : mais naaaaaan mais .. Rire
Rire
Micka : c'est trop dure quand tu saute
Squeezie : oue en faite ce qui est dure c'est que aaaah mais merde.  rire
Squeezie : On es bien la est micka regarde la vitesse de croisière olala tu va haut c'est toi qui va devoir switch
Ooooooooooh
Squeezie : excellent qu'elle travail d'équipe
Rire
Micka : Je vous assure que c'est pas moi je stresse trop
Squeezie : Naaaaan c'etait a toi d'allé .. Rire
Micka : c'est moi que est passer premier
Squeezie : alalaaa tu peu voir que mon score diminue
à tanger fès
Rire
Micka : j'ai stresser
Squeezie : définition de la panique
Squeezie : faut ce baisser maintenant oooh les enc****
Squeezie : Parfait ooh parfait on est sur une triple mort  , ta pas besoin de switch
Squeezie : ta fait bug le jeu mec ta fait planter le jeu !!  dans leur calcule ils n'avez pas pris en conte que de joueurs aussi mauvais pouvais mourir a cette endroit
Squeezie : olalalaaa putain on dirait de la gymnastique rythmique
Ohhhh j'ai pas vue
Baisse toi
switch
Yes , inverse inverse
Micka : Mais c'est a toi t'es derrière
Squeezie : A oui pardon
Rire
Squeezie : Ok vas-y te foire pas vas-y reste devant
Meurs pas meurs pas
Noooooooon tu ma stresser
On a réussit on a réussit on a réussit
Micka : J'ai plus de rond que toi
on a réussit on a réussit
on a réussit ok on passe
à la vraie difficulté le deuxième je
n'arrive plus à parler alors passons
tout de suite a dit et sans explication
et nouvelle mécanique ou pas c'est quoi
ça c'est des trucs qui disparaisse tu paries
non genre y'a que moi qui peux y aller ok
d'accord et la il y a que moi qui peut y aller
et je viens de rater et de tomber dans le vide finalement
Ah le pire égoïste
t'es vraiment mais arrête de faire sa  mec  tu vois ce que c'est de faire sa
ils nous formate en faisant croire
qu'il faut.. ok
le tout c'est de faire confiance à
l'autre ok faut juste pas paniqué j'ai paniqué
pourquoi te re switch
Mais pourquoi te re switch
Bah moi j'ai étoile et toi non
et ben Micka c'est la fin de cette vidéo
sur jogar nôtre ça s'appelait sais pas
c'était sympa mais assez facile
assez facile on retiendra le mot switch
en fait je vais faire un jeu de mots avec
katy perry switch switch mais en faite vu que c'est pas le même mot je me suis aperçu
en cour de route
abonnez vous n'hésitez pas à aimer
la vidéo si elle vouset a passer sur la chaine de micka
sa faisait longtemps que l'on avais pas jouer a un jeu comme sa
si longtemps depuis  iv mario
non quand même pas mais ça faisait
comme un pur moment ça fait plaisir
petit gaming etre poto même si on
est plus poto parce que tu as était  nuls aaah putain
mais casses toi ta put** c'est de ta faute
aaah j'ai pas fait exprès je t'es vraiment poussé
REVISION : ARMAND JANKOWIAK